lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
tomar la función igual a raíz cúbica de
x y la vamos a rotar alrededor del eje x
para obtener una figura como esta la
vamos a rotar entre x igual a 0 y x
igual a 8 y obtendremos algo que se ve
así y este volumen lo podrías calcular
fácilmente usando el método de discos
sin embargo te voy a mostrar otro método
el método de cascarones para calcular
volumen usaremos el método de cascarones
cuando giramos alrededor de un eje
horizontal que en este caso es el eje x
y cómo hacemos esto bien vamos a dibujar
un rectángulo vamos a dibujar aquí dicho
rectángulo
lo voy a hacer en este color salmón aquí
tenemos un rectángulo que tiene espesor
de y ese es el espesor de este
rectángulo y cuya longitud y cuya
longitud es 8 menos el valor de x que
tenemos aquí deja de ponerlo claramente
aquí abajo la longitud del rectángulo
esta longitud es igual a 8 menos el
valor de x correspondiente de este punto
y como puedes darte cuenta si aquí
tenemos de y vamos a estar integrando
con respecto a y sobre un intervalo en
el eje y entonces necesitamos tener la
función en términos de iu y como hacemos
esto bien si la curva es igual a raíz
cúbica de x despejando x obtenemos
entonces que x es igual a que kubica
estas dos expresiones son equivalentes
así es que aquí tenemos que esta
longitud 8 menos el valor de x en
términos de y que es que kubica 8 menos
que kubica de tal manera que cuando
giras este rectángulo alrededor del eje
x
se va a constituir en un cilindro
delgado o un cascarón como le llamamos
déjame dibujar aquí dicho cascarón
déjame lo voy a hacer lo mejor posible
voy a dibujar aquí este cilindro delgado
que es el cascarón determinado por ese
rectángulo aquí lo tenemos
y aquí lo tenemos de hecho comparten
esta estación en común con la con la
figura déjame darle un poco de
profundidad para que podamos ver
claramente ese cascarón y aquí lo
tenemos aquí tenemos entonces el
cascarón ahora si calculamos el volumen
de este cascarón quién sabemos que
corresponde al producto del área
superficial por el espesor de este
cascarón vamos a obtener volumen de este
cascarón que corresponde una y
específica y si sumamos los volúmenes de
los cascarones para todas las en el
intervalo vamos a obtener al final de
cuentas el volumen del sólido que nos
interesa entonces de nueva cuenta como
calculamos el volumen de este cascarón
bueno podemos calcular la circunferencia
de este lado o esta etapa esta etapa
izquierda o esta etapa derecha
calculamos la circunferencia de esta
etapa la cual como ya sabemos es igual
la circunferencia es igual a 2 pi por el
radio y cuánto vale el radio aquí cuánto
vale este radio bueno podemos ver que
este radio en ambas tapas corresponde al
valor de y aquí en el cascarón entonces
la circunferencia va a ser igual
y por ahora si queremos el área
superficial lo único que tenemos que
hacer es esta circunferencia por el
ancho de este cascarón por el largo de
este cascarón más bien dicho es decir
por ocho menos que cubica tenga el
ponerlo por aquí entonces área
superficial externa si queremos ser más
precisos esto va a ser igual a al valor
de la circunferencia que acabamos de
calcular que es igual a 2 ville
multiplicado por el largo del cascarón
que es 8 menos que kubica el área
superficial es el producto del largo por
la circunferencia del cascarón y cuál va
a ser el volumen de este cascarón bien
el volumen del cascarón va a ser el área
superficial 2 ville por 8 - que kubica
multiplicado por el espesor de este
cascarón por d y el espesor del cascarón
lo voy a poner aquí en color púrpura
multiplicamos entonces por de y este es
el volumen de un cascarón si queremos
obtener el volumen del sólido de
revolución tenemos que sumar todos
cascarones a medida que su espesor se
hace infinitamente pequeño y el número
de cascarones se hace infinitamente
grande tomemos entonces la suma vamos a
integrar y recuerda que estamos haciendo
todo en términos de yen entonces nuestro
volumen va a ser igual cuáles van a ser
los límites de nuestro integral
claramente inicia en cero y el límite
superior es cuando x es igual a 8 cuando
x es igual a 8 y es igual a raíz cúbica
de 8 que es igual a 2
este valor de aquí es 2 déjame ponerlo
claramente este valor es igual a 2
llevaría entonces de 0 a 2 y ya tenemos
nuestra integral y esta integral se ve
bastante siempre si es que vamos a
atacar la de una vez sacamos el 2 pide
la integral esto es 2 pi por la integral
de 0 a 2 vamos a hacer este producto en
el integrando esto va a ser igual 10 por
8 es igual a 8 y menos 4a todo esto
de i d i y esto es igual a 2 y vamos a
integrar vamos a encontrar la anti
derivada la anti derivada de 8 y es ocho
de cuadra sobre dos que es 4 y cuadrada
- la anti derivada de ye cuarta la anti
derivada de ye cuarta que es 10 quinta
sobre 5 y esto evaluado de 0 a 2 es
decir esto es igual a 2 pi evaluando en
el límite superior evaluando en 24 por 2
al cuadrado es 4x4 16 - de quinta
evaluada en 2 es 2 a la quinta que es 32
esto es menos 32 quintos en el límite
inferior cuando ya igual a cero la
expresión se anula esto es lo que
resulta entonces del integral
simplifiquemos esta expresión 16 menos
treinta y dos quintos
hagámoslo acá arriba 16 en quinto 6 16
por 5 igual 80 80 quintos esto es
equivalente a 16 y 80 quinto le vamos a
restar 32 quintos
80 quintos menos treinta y dos quintos
me da 48 quintos
esto es igual a 48 quintos
si está bien 80 menos 30 y 50 menos 248
cuarenta y ocho quintos esto va a ser al
final de cuentas nuestro gran final 48
por 12 96 déjame hacerlo con otro color
para indicar que ya es el resultado
final 48 por 12 296 por pi quintos 96 pi
quintos y de nueva cuenta te menciono
que este volumen también lo podríamos
haber encontrado por el método de discos
integrando con respecto a x nosotros lo
hicimos por el método de cascarones o el
método de los cilindros delgados
integrando con respecto a qué